i have the pleasure of talking to you guys about durable mrd negativity i think we're talking about
potential or hopeful durability because as you've heard already and i'll review with you guys we
don't know how durable the mrd is going to be but summary in three seconds is by specifics targeting
bcma whether after transplant instead of transplant or even integrated into induction therapy mrd
rates are going to be outstanding so how long it's going to last we don't know hopefully forever and
ever and ever but again changing how we think about taking care of our patients especially
those that maybe aren't benefiting as much from our current quad induction therapy you need more
but we kind of went through the goals already how durable is it going to be we don't know
but again as you heard this morning scott did a great job of saying we should use these
earlier because we have better t cells we have more fit cells cells might be
patients may be sent more sensitive we still have high risk we have to worry about so i like
chat gtp is where i do this one from but the bottom line is where do we use them earlier
right so is it after we give transplant so you're mopping everything up i think it's really
really important for folks who have high risk disease do you do it instead of we put another
dagger in the heart of high dose therapy and autologous stem cell transplant sorry sir
uh or do we integrate and again we heard a lot of great talks about integration we're going to go
backwards from scott's talk this morning talking about maintenance then to transplant or instead
of transplant and then we'll go to kind of integrate there and then we haven't really
talked much about it and i'm going to gloss over it but gprc5d is also a cool target and i think
may be more important on some levels but a different way of looking at the same kind
of context is we have a lot of really cool studies looking at bi-specifics in the late relapse
disease setting early relapse we heard about majestic 3 already today and how amazing it is
in terms of early relapse therapy as well as other studies looking at other bcma by specifics but
really can we start talking about how we're going to put these things again in the newly diagnosed
setting either against consolidation or otherwise there's a lot of studies to talk about that we're
not going to get through all of them today and then also smoldering myelin can we make disease
altering therapeutic decisions early on in therapy before they have active disease and maybe we've
been talking a little bit about how we can change the patients uh lifestyles even from that
perspective so what do we do post transplant we heard about this this morning a little bit so
again the safety run in um from majestic four uh cesar i think is leading the america the us version
of this right and i'm still coming into my group to do it so we'll keep working on it but
essentially look at three different cohorts and the bottom line is we're going to see different
dosing strategies with tech tech len or tech alone and you know you have small numbers of
patients again safety running we're going to hear more about it as we get the random
ization going but the bottom line is looking at just response rates like greater than cr rates
you're doing fantastic you're upgrading everybody then mrd was the title of my slides so what does
mrd look like i just changed the colors from other people's slides but essentially every 100
mrd negative right so again i'm outstanding ways of cleaning people's cleaning people's uh disease
up after transplant uh i think this is a really cool study this is kind of how i think about
looking again maybe instead of or after induction therapy this is a muni plant that deco presented it
ash this year looking at limbo celtumab after six cycles of induction therapy they got really up to
six cycles of linvo uh i didn't design the slide that's next but deco did so but trust me in here
the bottom line is if you got limbo for four or six cycles your mrd negative rate was 100 so again
in a setting of cleaning up after induction therapy quad or triplet induction therapy
and patients could go on to get maintenance therapy after up to
up to physician choice but again other data demonstrating that we really can clean up disease
that has already been treated by outstanding therapy we learned this morning that for drug
therapy does some amazing things for newly diagnosed patients as well so my brain is how
can we use this to build on that that foundation but obviously can we just replace it is also
another thought as well um i think we heard about the faster study which is coming on to also
consolidate but integration into a newly diagnosed therapy we heard about linker for this morning
where you know single agent uh limbo is being used driving mrd rates is going to be outstanding and
mrd rates and the small number that's been looked at so far again a fantastic job there again so
integration with a single agent what if we oh they turn back red sorry about that
uh what if we use it uh in majestic five right so instead of induction with combination therapies
in different arms what are we going to get there we know oh look mrd rates 100 for everybody again
these are things that are amazing changes in how we're thinking about taking care of our patients
today uh tech lil i think is another cool study where it's tech versus tech dera uh versus tech len
so kind of our two favorite old school therapies without a pi using a bcma Bispecific and again
we'll learn more and more about this but as we know great response rates in the cohort a aspect
mgs negative six a hundred percent so again some amazing bcma Bispecific theories he's
integrated into induction therapy um again magnetism six we heard a little bit earlier
as well looking at the same story great uh deeper levels of response i think what they presented it
this year was really nice because it talked about infection something we'll have to think about with
all classes of drug all bcma targeting agents is we have to think about what that looks like
and i think majestic three taught us a lot about that as well as there are infections we have to
make sure we're mitigating so just as a highlight not a specific comment on this one is all bcma
bites in my opinion is infection something to think about and so mitigation strategies are
critical ivig antivirals etc are all critical things to make sure and pjp pro flex all
incredible things to help make sure your patients are doing well especially in this newly diagnosed
setting um so summary i'm going to finish early because lunch is there finnette you're welcome
actually i might pontificate for a while and we'll see what we can do anyway so treatment goals
continue to evolve in the face of our new evolving landscape very very impressive mrd negative rates
when you talk about bcma targeting therapies after quad induction as well as after transplant
and i think really unprecedented data even when you integrate into induction therapy
and you're changing those strategies again so again we are in the midst of
changing the goals of therapy i think at least for some where we can think about maybe
maybe finite therapies when we get mrd adapted approaches to holding therapy or de-escalating
but i'd really have to think it's just at least for some we all have these patients that are
really high risk i always tell the story you know the last month i've had like three or four
50 year olds who are not going to be with us much longer because they still have high risk disease
and they should be around they aren't benefiting from all the amazing things we have the way we'd
like them to they're around because they've been on the mall but for not very long so again
how can we better integrate these things and again maybe sequence these things to
help these patients do better so again we are on the brink of change i think when i came
into this business we were trying to control disease we've been in an era of functional cure
i think maybe we can actually be where we're actually increasing the cure fraction in a
realistic way of myeloma with integration of these really amazing therapies again beast
made bites for this discussion but CAR-T is part of as well on top of what we've already done so
i'll stop there and lunch is served